[Music]
what can you expect when you create a
roster stacked with superstars
occasionally you get to see a real
synergy of talent and flashes of
greatness Arsenal toward the firebox and
hope of a killer all in one position a
guardian makes it dominate New York in
2017 to the Barclays Center all the way
through this tournament now and then you
see dominant personalities clash when he
first moved here I mean I know what to
expect I knew him and adrenaline get
along very well I knew it would probably
be like a ticking time bomb and you know
only a matter of time until it exploded
where simple made it either him or a
dren and you know obviously as we can
see now it's that was what it was and
once in a while the parts work together
so well that long-standing rivalries
turn into unstoppable friendships but
sometimes what sounds good in theory
doesn't take form in practice sometimes
what you end up with is so hilariously
bad that it compels you both to laugh
and cry we just want to win a series so
badly like we just want to make
ourselves probably want to make the fans
proud and for League of Legends fans
that's exactly what Delta Fox was in the
most tragic fashion available we just
did everything right and then and then
we didn't
now if you've never watched a league of
Legends Challenger Series game in your
life don't feel bad
very few people did challenger was a
promotion based system where
up-and-coming league rosters and talent
would try to make their names and
hopefully earn an entry into the highest
tiers of regional competition however in
spite of challengers intent to launch
the game's next generation of stars it
struggled to regularly capture even the
most devout league fans attention but
that changed in June of 2017 when echo
Fox surprisingly announced the revival
of its wayward sibling team Delta Fox
now to og League of Legends fans Delta
Fox's new roster provided an overdose of
nostalgia it was a ragtag outfit made up
of former pro players that had gone on
to become some of the game's most
successful streamers it was a goddamn
meme super team in the top lane you had
a markus dyrus hill a decorated TSM
legend whose love for pillows was
eclipsed only by his hatred for CLG as
far as I know the only na team that I'm
worried about is cloud 9 the rest are
non-existent
especially CEO G
joining him was William scarily a
jack-of-all-trades content creator with
the heart of gold filling in as the
team's jungler I'm gonna try to come up
with a big flash I'm literally gonna
flash and see if I can and then there
was Joe dat voy voy Esfahani a slick
big-brained midlane veteran known for
adding insult to injury
Ziya nerds then of course in ad carry
was Michael I'm a cutie pie Santana a
prehistoric-looking goofball known for
his self-replicating locks and unmatched
love for League of Legends and last but
not least there was Danny shift early
high elo leagues favorite food
aficionado he'd be stepping in to play
support and occasionally the recorder at
first the community's reaction to this
streaming super team was mostly positive
and Delta Fox's combined star power was
enough to generate some serious hype
around the often overlooked challenger
scene a lot of people were super excited
when it was announced like Oh Delta Fox
is coming back like oh my god whoa a
cutie shifter Diaries Skaar the boys the
squad like they're gonna rock it they're
gonna get first place in Challenger
Series they're gonna make it to LCS like
this is the dream now obviously this
looked like a clever publicity stunt on
the part of echo fox but the
organization claimed there was genuine
belief that the team could succeed
the end goal always is to to try to win
that I mean if you're competing this is
a competitor is not a joke
challengers used to be is not something
that isn't taken seriously so you had a
team of mechanically skilled and
experienced stars of yester League
banding under the banner of a
reputable eSports organization what
could possibly go wrong
well for starters Delta Fox was made up
of three natural mid laners but with
voyboy calling dibs on that roll SCARA
and shifter were given the difficult
task of learning how to play jungle and
support on top of that obvious hurdle
Delta Fox may have been good
individually in soloqueue but they
lacked the coordination that comes from
playing together regularly as a team and
it showed seemed to be working out for
big guys jackals specifically in the
early game player here there are two
player own the emo flank and the
exclusive Kass go up up by Anna's
already picked up a kill on shifter boy
boys hanging through the tower you have
to music I England cool stars gonna
flash into the wall not be able to get
away from that one now here comes Pekin
woof dyrus is use that teleport is he
able to pick up any more than just to
kill on to search it looks like know he
gets played he gets taken down PI on oh
yeah they're being kind of corralled by
Chris and Keegan Woolford Hickman was a
little bit on the back side here but
Chris continuing to chase down pops
indominus to hug that available to pick
up and kill a couple now except this one
p3 turns into a 2 before is that our
side finally because he gets CCD goes
down the Challenger gatekeeper flashing
his skills here one versus three and
here comes Bordeaux because I'm playin
dignifying can't do anything what B
three where's the team cutie-pie calls
in this and his chat
looks like the hook Delta Fox gonna be
forced under their own base taken down
by big God's jackals they're gonna take
a - oh here over their opponents 27th
metagame - well played the big guys
echoes - came - absolutely convincing
smash from start to finish some good
team fights to boot as well GG - out
still sadly for dump a box no game wins
at all this is one of their easier
opponents the fourth-placed team mult
elta fox are full of veteran LCS players
with strong mechanical abilities are
struggling to find wins against any of
the organized challenger squads here in
the split now that would have been
easily corrected had they implemented a
regular practice schedule but bafflingly
they were encouraged not to we were just
like 5 streamers that were at the last
second asked to play together and
compete in Challenger Series
we all wanted to do our best want to
have fun with it but at the very least I
thought that we'd be able to practice
but after we did like one scrim block on
stream we were actually told that we
weren't allowed to stream any of our
scrims again because apparently we like
got too many viewers combined or
something like that it was like a really
weird thing the only way we could ever
practice after we were told that was if
we all completely change our stream
schedules and practice for like you know
big blocks off stream and we did if we
did it a few times but like it was hard
to do it consistently compared to like
these teams that were literally
practicing you know 12 hours a day
together and like living and gaming
houses and stuff the team was at a
crossroads on one hand they could all
take time away from their lucrative
streaming careers and reinvested in a
robust scrim schedule that would enable
them to be more competitive on the other
they could continue raking in money on
stream and taking their weekly
challenger wulfings like grown-ass men
I'm sure you can imagine which option
they chose pre-six dives in the game and
he isn't a bad spot here it comes
puts on their follow-up stun and dandy
sinks his fangs in first place it's
clinical too easy a few moments later
another stun another slice and dice and
dandy gets two kills for the price of
one he was dead at that point I guess he
figured he can't get away a flash way
from the cutie pie dodged on me
everybody gets dogs back him but a
seismic stuff hazel is in the area just
as the forest war boy teleports into
that fight tried to get something done
to hear his entrance is there a teleport
back from liquor she wants to join the
freaky to kill for him someone to give
it it over the Deathly and assist picked
up tell the Fox now just beaten away
killed 9 to 2 in favor be United
shifter going down as well very quickly
after that there's no hope for delphox
win that fight
there's no smite to confess this bear
but look a might want to it anyways
trying to get them pills down to clean
us on up those beautified dashes
backwards are trying to cut this out
Syrus is still in the front line but
they both left on to start and to defy
us to try to flash away there's no one
else in the scene to try to help him
whatsoever double kill secured by
licorice for three and three at another
point so nervous transition of early
advantage into something for him is that
licorice might be caught out here the
flag and drag go his dad but cutie pie
and Shara both washed out immediately as
soon as I see that hero's engines
landing down dump of us looking for
fights but more will be locked up in the
back line he was exhausted he's trying
to survive but he's gonna want it going
down definitely picks up the first hill
from that one Dan he's gonna want to
block him down on the shifter near that
I started to fight on the liquorice he's
gonna be the one that helps the finish
it as a double kill goes over to the
Baron now that's not to say that the
Delta Fox Squad wasn't trying or didn't
want to succeed after all they were
naturally competitive so regularly
taking l's against motivated and well
practiced opposition became a grating
source of frustration every game we play
like we enjoy it a lot but I'm not gonna
lie like it's really frustrating like
getting some advantages in some of these
games and then just kind of throwing or
like eventually getting smashed because
we really want to win like we're all
super motivated to do well for the fans
and like there's so much riding on our
backs and we hate letting everyone down
so these losses definitely hurt I want
to win and have the clean of like rah
like rally up behind us like oh yeah
dude Delta Fox do you shifter tires
cutie
scar avoid you know they're popping off
and stuff and I just want everyone have
fun with it and I guess like tough ones
that you just have to win which is like
totally understandable I totally get it
but yeah it just feels bad because we
really do want to do it for the fans but
unfortunately for Delta Fox getting
smacked down week after week an
Challenger led to a lot of the community
turning on them the biggest thing I
didn't realize is actually all the like
flame actually it really takes me back
because I mean flame now more than when
I like underperformed on Dignitas when I
was a mid laner
with the mounting pressure to win a
series resting on their rusty
unpracticed shoulders Delta Fox
continued to fall further behind in the
standings here comes the curtain call
Omar God trying to get the knock up he's
super been picked up yet another kill
absolute zero does absolutely nothing
for SCARA except get himself caught on
to the tower
Tuesday now joining the fight he says
today is my day gyrus you come back here
Johnny goes and Tuesday pick that one up
at cutie pie it's Cara Lynn ballet now
he's in a position especially a
wraparound gank off his bot Lane of
Steel G Academy who don't really seem to
know at all where he is all right way to
go scar he is able to go over the wall
flashes up does knock up fill forces a
heel and a flash from the bot lane of
counter logic gaming Kadim E but now the
damage is getting turned around scars
does not ignite going down to D taking
tower talk fours to flash away and now
shifter is all alone in front he does
not have flash and he's going to be in a
lot of trouble zags gonna pick this one
up first blood heading on over to
counter logic gaming Academy flash
poured into a hook and fill the port is
able to foretell the future get the nice
hook ball abandoned with a slicing
maelstrom boy boy goes up and does kill
up fallen bandit everyone still alive on
Delta Fox nevermind there goes Tuesday
he's popping up one two three kills
heading on over to the side of CLG
Academy it's a double double kill Kuti
find the last one on the menu able to
use the blast comb to get out of trouble
but Tuesday kind of temple cutie pie the
pie goes down he tastes delicious and
it's an ace heading on over to the side
of CLG academy for Delta Fox the end of
the 2017 summer split simply couldn't
have come quick enough despite their
best efforts they finished in dead last
with an Owen ten record winning only
three games of the 23 they played in
total quite a few our mattress we won
games we popped off in plenty of them we
just never like you know - Oh tour - one
two team it was always like 1 1 or 1 2
or sometimes - I mean I think with a
little more practice we would have been
able to actually do a lot better
probably not win Challenger series of
course compared to the other teams that
were grinding hard every day but I'm
sure we would have at least taken a few
extra matches and made
fountain fans a little bit prouder and
you know ourselves a little bit prouder
in the process but I feel like even
though we went 0 and 10 we did take a
couple of games off of what you would
say with the better challenger teams and
I honestly think that itself losing to
us without any practice is pretty
embarrassing for them I think it's kind
of the middle ground between failure and
success and even though Delta Fox's
overall performance left a lot to be
desired and they came under a lot of
fire from fans not everyone saw their
adventure as a total disaster in no way
do do I look at the time there and
challenger with with Delta Fox's having
been a failure this year I think what
we've accomplished is we've had great
players we re-engage with with League
and with a desire to to defeat and
compete at a high level and the record
may not show it but I have to think that
across the board it is reignited their
competitive fire for the players however
the writing was on the wall as far as
Delta Fox was concerned they had a blast
reliving their competitive pasts but it
was time to refocus on their streaming
careers that team was just for the
further one split if we had like won the
Challenger series or something that and
like earned in LCS spot then I guess
maybe there would have been some talks
but I think everyone kind of understood
we were just gonna try our best and you
know try to make the best of the
opportunity and the time that we were
given whether it was a publicity stunt
or a bonafide attempt at making the
memes super teamwork Delta Fox's
catastrophic run was the storyline that
the Challenger scene desperately needed
and while we only got to see this
hilariously painful journey for one
split there entertaining struggle did
teach us one important lesson is that no
matter how much experience you have how
talented you are or how much weight your
name might carry if you're not
practicing as a team you're probably not
gonna win but that's ok because
sometimes winning isn't everything we
manage to have fun with in it in our own
way like there was some games or we
would just spell out bands like we'd ban
like pizza by banning the champions that
start with the letter
Pei zza for example like we did a bunch
of silly stuff like that so we
definitely still had a good time with it
even though it wasn't we weren't
competitively successful as a team so I
think at the end of day that's like what
we remember the most then you know what
we get to keep in our hearts last yeah
that's how we do it man that's how I
always failed it failed to capture
however in spite of challengers intent
to launch the games the next generation
of stars it failed
[ __ ] me next generation of stars it
failed to rip all my god okay last time
I'm getting a mess then we're done [ __ ]
this line [ __ ] this line [ __ ] League of
Legends all right [ __ ] everything that
has to do with either of them however in
spite of challengers intense flashes
keep this line is kicking my ass dude
all right
it's rough out here bro it's rough out
here all right all right
can't hit my shots today this is bad